[Music]
I think feminism that doesn't benefit
man is not my feminism I mean does it
really exist because feminism is
something about a call is he right it's
um
it means feminist means that you can
choose what kind of gender from like so
you'll see a gender as a palette and you
can draw with this palette freely and
ideally you would have as much power
order creating yourself as a piece of
art as you can so like I see that tester
that's their meaning of developing of
evolving as a human being or is it the
human humanity right so we were giving
will and we were giving mind for some
reason I guess to define ourselves to to
think about our social
presence and to think to redefine our
existence by ourselves
and within our community and within our
society so feminism it's a great tool
that helps us to understand actually
that throughout the history for some
reason the one part of humanity was
deprived from having basic human rights
from self from for some weird reason
that they don't have a dick right they
don't have deep if you don't have deep
then you have to then you have to I
don't know be the baby be a slave
that's strange right and so feminism is
about equality and how feminism can be
against men I don't know it is really
interesting for me as for Russian
activists there is still a question here
whether women have right to have a
person they're not you know in Russia
it's completely out of the question
like we just do have this right and like
you know snow is white women have right
to have versions that's it end of story
and then mister to the sink like what
why why is like that and in Russia
because you know like we're
unfortunately for a lot of American
people it's kind of obvious that Russia
is it's not as developed as America
which is not true at all we had amazing
experience of Soviet experiment and you
know it brought us a lot of terrible
things including extinction of
philosophy and art and me is like
philosophy student really suffers from
that but at the same time it brought a
lot of brilliance things you know strong
feminism socialist movement
and in the beginning of 20s our present
women once and for all I think realized
that they do have right to control their
bodies then so they were given right to
have abortion in 20s then they lost is
right and when Stalin came to power but
then they got it back in 1953 and since
then they always had this right I didn't
like to enter unless the things with
nasty words or they like when even when
I was attacked in McDonald's in Moscow
was this green medicine liquid in my
eyes and it's some metal objects thrown
in my and mashes my colleague heads like
what I did at that instance I just came
to those people and hugged them and then
asked that quite what did you do that
and then I thought I saw that I saw
something in their eyes like they did
they were they started to say that
actually we are human beings because you
know this this beginning of world where
you want to dehumanize other so yeah I
don't want to dehumanize people who hate
feminism
[Music]